last Oscar is for Best Picture and the
nominees are the fugitive
Arnold Copeland producer in the name of
the father Jim Sheridan producing
the piano John Chapman producing
the remains of the day Mike Nichols John
Kelly Ismail merchant producing
Schindler's List Steven Spielberg Gerald
our Mullen Franco lose weight producers
and the Oscar for the Best Picture of
1993 goes to Schindler's List Steven
Spielberg Gerald Mullen and Branco this
week producer
well thank you thank you
oh wow this is this this this is the
best drink of water after the longest
drought in my life let me just be brief
because I would like Jerry and Bronco to
say something but let me just say there
are 350,000 survivors of the Holocaust
alive today
I implore all the educators who are
watching this program to please do not
allow the Holocaust to remain a footnote
in history please teach this in your
schools there are 350,000 experts who
just want to be useful with the
remainder of their lives please listen
to the words and the echoes and the
ghosts and please teach this in your
schools thank you very very much for
this
just very quickly thank you to the
Academy to a brilliant cast and a
marvelous international crew to my wife
Pat for sharing the magic for the past
40 years and to Steven Spielberg for
your courage and dedication to purpose
that has given each and every one of us
such a special and marvelous gift thank
you my number was a three three one
seven I'm a Holocaust survivor it's a
long way from Auschwitz to this stage I
want to thank everyone who helped me to
come so far people died in front of me
on the camps the last words were be a
witness of my murder tell to the world
how I died remember together with Jerry
by helping Steven to make this movie I
hope I fulfill my obligation to the
innocent victims of the Holocaust in the
name of the six million Jews killed in
the Shaw and other Nazis victims I want
to thank everyone who our knowledge this
movie thank you
you